τις ψήφους που μπορείαφερείο αβεροφοόνου φριο οκουλάς οχαρίς ο γιοργιάδης ο δίπλαρωσεις τη λέμες όρ
αλλά θα μπορούν να δημουργήσουν μια νέα ενικόνα που θα κάνει παραδοσιακού συναγερμικούς να σηκωθούν
που των καναπε να παναψηφίσουν το μεγάλον πρόβλημα του συναγερμού είναι ότι αρχί ζιπληωνή απόσταση
της υγεσίας από τη βάσεη να μεγαλών οι πολύ και τούτον το πληρώνει στην κάλ
και στα κόματα του καιέντροφανανα υπάρχει μια πτωτική τάση και αναζητούν κια κινηλύσει με ψηεφοδέλτεια
και ονόματα από τη νέαγένια ώστε κάποια να μην μίνουν εκτός βουλής και κάποια να
μη μίνου σε χαμηλές πτης ντάξει προσπαθούν να θεραπεύσουν μια θανατηφόρανρώστια με τσιρώα στιχώρον του
ιένρο νομίζω ότι εκεί επαίρχεται το μιραίων σε κάθε εκλογικίννοναμέτριση ακόμα πιο γρήγορα και οι
λύσεις που έχουν να πρωτίνουν είναι ας πιρίνες δηλαδή ελάτε όλοι μαζί να σμίξουμε όσες
προσπάθει ξέρετε στην πολίτη στην εκλογική πολιτική ίν υπάρχει εξήσμα θηματική φορμουλα οι προσθέτης δύο
κόμματα μαζί το αποτέλεσμα είναι πιο χαμηλών από το ανεκατεβαίνα μόνη τους οσυναγερμός ότανείναι διασπάσθηκε
το δύο χιλάδες τέσσρα στις ευροεκλογές του δέσσρα τες πρτες ήταν οι μονα η πρώτη
φορα πο διασπάσθηκε νοδημιουργηθήκαδύο σχήματα ευύχαρεντρεις επροβουλευτές οι διάσπαση αυξάνει οι συςοι συμμαχίες στην κοινάψει
φοδέλςτια μειώνοντα πος ωστά αρά και εκεί να σου κάμω μια πρόβλεψη αν τα κόμματα
του ενδιάμεσου χώρου κατεβούν όλα μαζί θα ποιάσουν πιο χαμηλών ποσ ωστόνα πατελί από ότι
επιασαν ξεχωριστά ο καθένας στην προηγούμενη φάμε λίγο και στο σύμβουλος επικεινωνίας απάμεο πολιτικός σήμερα
ξαρταδα πλήρως από την ικώνα κενικών α που βλέπουμε νομίζω να ύξαρτάτη νομίζει και δυστυχώς
βλέπουμε φαινόμενα τα οποία δείχνουν ότι έχειείναι όλα μια φοδογρα